and as we see a new leading variant in
covet cases CDC numbers showing only 34
percent of eligible people though have
the most up-to-date booster Madison
Kimbrough spoke with a doctor who
specializes in vaccines along with
people on The Strip about their thoughts
on the most recent booster and if they
feel it's necessary
I've had coveted twice and uh
my nose got stuffy and it was gone after
like a week I've not been boosted I
don't think it's uh necessary whether
it's the common cold the flu or covid
tis the season for getting sick and
while many out there are dealing with
some sort of illness many have decided
not to get additional vaccines to
protect themselves according to the CDC
63 percent of residents living in the
Las Vegas area are fully vaccinated
while only 26 percent are boosted since
2021 there have been three boosters
released Dr Jonathan bucktari CEO of E7
Health says he has his own theories on
why the boosters are less popular you
already took you know two three vaccines
you got covered
it's hard to convince someone to then go
get a booster especially a booster that
doesn't cover the current strains the
CDC says 80 percent of the population is
partially vaccinated within the U.S with
68 percent being fully vaccinated Mark
Jones sharing with eight news now that
the only reason he got vaccinated was
because it was is mandatory for work
Jones doesn't think a booster will keep
him from getting coveted in the future I
didn't mind getting the the first
initial
I had to for work anyways to keep my job
but uh after that and looking around at
all the people that continue to get it
that still have and to keep passing away
that even have the boosters you know
since they get no more
that was Madison Kimbrough reporting
more data on the new xbb one five latest
estimates from the CDC show it is now
the leading variant in these new covet
cases nearly doubling its percentage
share of all cases that's across the
country the week heading into Christmas
it was at 21 percent projections for
this past week are up to 40 percent
though hospitalizations are up just
slightly experts don't believe this
variant carries a greater danger really
than any others and the same prevention
measures are encouraged